[Music]
[Music]
800 kinds of burger shaker that's like
10 years ago and I know mother [ __ ]
life is so good that's how they
complained it man there's still a
millionaire just from that song alone
till this day and I'm in the wrong
business we gotta make a club it and
then retire we gotta talk about how
sweat drips down testicles even if
you're weighing underwear maybe if it's
a hot day drip like chili oil a bit dope
club's long well that's what ash juice
does oh yeah just living up the old high
school totally being about high school -
hey man just having some rent a booty on
your penis it was nice I just remember
all the times I was red as [ __ ] it in
those clubs drinking beer the art of
twerking has really evolved since our
time oh yeah how do you shake it in our
time yeah booty shaky frickin bad streak
dancing as I said it was like no front
piggybacking they say nice girl they be
like now for this homecoming I don't
want to see any front piggy backing
breathe
it's like sacrilege can you do a
piggybacking on the front of the
shoulders yeah and I was super they were
super down and fine with that
yeah nice school was weird very specific
rules yeah prison guard was fired for
illegally obtaining a McDonald's
discount yeah be taking those discounts
and they're gonna I don't think this
man's really elderly yeah what would
qualify a McDonald's discount other than
being McDonald's employee maybe service
member or like what what does it oh
there's like a military discount from
McDonald or maybe not that kind of like
a first responder right police officer
Jeffrey Morse code copper firefighters
got it nurse no notice people like
paramedic curse this happened in New
Zealand and this prison guard was
impersonating a police officer to get a
discount on a Big Mac and 10-piece
chicken nugget meal yeah that's it was
that like 50 cents off I mean my
McDonald's might be more expensive in
Australia 24 is chicken nuggets Mahmoud
ah how much they got a 24 nugget out
there
now when they give you a 20 piece they
don't give you a big box they just give
you two boxes of ten piece oh I don't
know what the [ __ ] they did with the
bigger box man McDonald what are you
doing it's more delicious it's way more
delicious and I hate opening [ __ ] box
to multiple boxes man no it does the
[ __ ] big one does the same thing and
it's actually warmer cuz it's all the
food together yeah I think is that
they're trying to minimize waste by
having two different sizes and just
ordering a lot of one side but wouldn't
that sorry I meant waste of money
oh I missed the big time it's the big
box because you had the big box you
could put the sauce on the side inside
the big box yeah open up these two
separate boxes
it's off to the side they should be
paying you imagine you get a large soda
right and instead of eating one large
soda to give you two so what are you
gonna do a too small I like that
and with you out of what I don't want I
do the [ __ ] afraid David I keep telling
you David yeah right here under the
frame see each other so we like
naturally we keep doing this they slip
your face out
help me up alright anyway oh oh so they
say that his name is Lawrence he's 43
years old he pleaded guilty to
impersonating it sounded like a dating
profile at first yeah wait
his name is Lawrence he hates the beach
she's a big liar and a cop
he sings a cop yeah so he was fired but
he's kind of a cop right through the
guard the gardener thought that suck
Stoker's like correctional guards they
still got to go to Academy like a police
like Academy but just because they're
not on patrol they don't they're not
considered a first responder they're
cops so it kind of sucks so they're like
TSA know they go to Academy though
so are they sworn officer peace officers
under the post certification so afraid
they'll take their own hose his ID card
said NSW Police
- external contractor so the Macdonald
staff was like wait why does it say its
no no conscience give it to him hold on
within the FBI taking care of serial
killers they're rapists
give him a Big Mac yeah so then he was
like oh I'm actually a police officer
this is my off-duty badge so then the
McDonald's workers are like this is
fishy so then they took you care about
your [ __ ] McDonald's job that much I
wouldn't give up [ __ ] dude
would I go to McDonald's right like can
I get an extra packet of ketchup ever
been a manager anywhere you worked Men's
Wearhouse tux manager yeah I was
assistant manager but see like why are
you so investigative if I saw a male
stripper come in with a cop outfit with
daisy dukes and he goes give me a big
meth
batboy Oh give me a cop discount Wow
came up big guys and he was like I'm a
cop here take the 10% you little [ __ ]
these who the [ __ ] here so this 50% 50%
of a $7 under the thousands of sales
will happen the beach I'm sorry I said
if he's a stripper he's already used to
things being 50% off thanks McDonald's
employee they took a photo of the bank
card on their face Oh contacted the
police that's all my god you hall
monitor [ __ ] wait a minute though what
if they what if they were like what if
he's doing this everywhere else not for
the sake of disc one who gets hurt
pulling people over or you're going
there are a lot of people that do a
person ain't officers to to do fraud you
do best I know but you just want to get
a discount baby you know that maybe they
may be job to do that I wouldn't even do
that I would just look at him and I
would publicly shame him dude I would
say first of all I'm not even upset that
you're personally a police officer this
is five dollars what is going on in your
life what are you doing it's five
dollars dude
New Zealand has awesome like health care
and government aid installed what's that
like are you gonna scam a McDonald's bro
it's just embarrassed our buddies are
police officers so they get hella
discounts everywhere they go but he
tells me that if they go there even
though they're used to eating discounts
if they don't give him the discount they
never demand it so all of those guys
probably just knew at the cash register
like he feels he feels like a douche
going like hmm yeah yes for him he's
just like I think you know there's like
pretty crazy to like though it's like $3
for like a $20 meal almost damn it's
super today they're like really really
friendly but if he doesn't get it so
just pay the 20 bucks he's like yeah
that's fits fine so this is Lauren which
one another Jordan Peele look-alike I
know dude bill burr yeah Jordan Peele
dude oh just pay for the bird
a good lawyer I'm assuming but yes this
guy God Devils jacked what the [ __ ]
damn John pill he's a security guard
looks different in everybody that those
goatee is so thick Ulis fake that Bulls
head doesn't even look like to touch
that ball right that's how big is my arm
is huge I like that they put the Big Mac
down there in case you don't know it's
Maori or some [ __ ] for sure dude yeah
the rock over here dude
yeah he's mentally never even questions
somebody that size yeah I saw him I'm
like he's a police officer for sure yeah
I bet you the workers are just that
sighs - so they're like all the same way
smaller than the workers yeah yeah we're
just like wait a minute bro yeah we got
a little 6 5 guy here right now hey
little funny get the [ __ ] out here on
the register dudes are seven feet or
whatever I don't think I would have ever
cared about my part-time job that much
to to go out of my way - well - it
wasn't even like no no that he talked
about the McDonald oh my god yeah well
they get paid well like they get paid
like 20 bucks and hours I would probably
care about my job a lot then like you
know because if I'm getting paid cause a
compensator right yeah yeah I mean when
we went to Australia years ago I
remember being mind blown at like their
McDonald's employees they get paid like
18 or something at the time like a
livable wage yeah okay I'm just I was
like how's about that yeah cuz I thought
it was you know over here it's a very
minimum you know what I mean like shitty
ass everything yeah do anything with it
yeah so who raised if you're 40 are you
gonna raise a family and we're gonna
retail working McDonald's I heard that
it's just a like a job a job is a job
you know it's like a regular job like
it's not like here where it's like
reserved for high school students and
immigrants and a stepping-stone for a
job yeah that's kind of cool well I was
wrong so it's a different environment I
bet that's why they're probably like
that's a really bold guy cuz seeing a
man like that tatted up it just his big
eyes he knows I'm a cop like a [ __ ] you
are you could say whatever you want to
do you could tell me you're a [ __ ]
unicorn I believe it dude I think is a
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] maybe they knew
cuz they're like trying to be a cop and
that's their part-time job and [ __ ]
they're like no you're not what if that
was like the 40th time he already went I
still give it to him because he looks
like he could kill me he's on the SWAT
team and that's why we don't work the
register at our own shops exactly you
know how much money we move super easy
dude come on and the CIA agent I'm Jesus
Christ you probably are last time I was
there I started giving out all this free
product and I was like damn this is why
I can't work here man I wanted everybody
to try the soft serve well unplug the
saucer machine and gave to somebody you
want a franchise here's cash yes so he
was arrested when he went to work on
Year's Eve well rested him too so he was
convicted of impersonating an office of
police officer but he was granted a
section 10 non conviction in court which
means he'll not receive a criminal
record or the effect that's good like at
best that's like a mistake and a
not-so-great
person thing to do to get a discount
like it wasn't like he was pulling
people over it's getting a discount so
like slap on the wrist maybe lose the
job don't give him a public she did lose
yeah yeah yeah so burgers at his face
that are happy eat medic any oh yeah
public shaming wanted half off well I
could think about is how delicious
McDonald's in New Zealand might be oh
yeah because you know how there's like
regional things in sausage and never
heard of your trip to McDonald's
headquarters it's a secret no it's
[ __ ] awesome you know what okay long
story short I went to hamburger
University awesome
yeah they have their own restaurant
they're downstairs
it's so cool they have this McDonald's
but they have international like
McDonald's items they're cool so you
don't even have to wonder you could have
tried New Zealand oh it's rotational
it's not all of the country stuff so
like do pitch like when I was there at
the moment I had like a macho macho like
much watch a lot day Col it was like a
looks like a smoothie matcha smoothie
but it's like they have that item in
Japan you know they just it's just dope
and I met them one of the main chefs was
like McDaniel that doesn't yeah nine
yeah my name is Jeff chef Mike shot us
to chef Mike so he's pretty cool he
actually is
at the headquarters they use like prime
ass ain't Angus meat like like a
different kind of meat
I like how to specify at the head well
you know the one that we get it's like
dog great that's why it tastes so good
it's like is it the same great they use
for dog food if they put McDonald's
seasonings in it I would you know the
chicken nugget yeah yeah when you get it
fresh by the guy that invents that [ __ ]
it's chicken
no it's fried to perfection it's always
been shake and it got cold right cuz we
did a photo shoot with it
so we got cold but we still didn't want
to waste it and it was still good the
cold McNugget was still good have you
ever gotten then chicken McNuggets hands
done and mine I didn't the best I've
ever gotten is the McDonald's in Barstow
the McDonald's in Barstow
but the Del Taco Barstow is good too the
best thing ever though that tops that is
a [ __ ] fresh made [ __ ]
filet-o-fish from where the one right
over here
wanna see laughs yeah I got a fresh
[ __ ] one dude you know the thing is
you got to eat it fresh like the fries
everything yeah and then bacon hours
coming you got put you can put all kinds
of bacon and everything
[Music]
[Music]